et nous sommes avec philippe ehrbeck le
secrétaire général de la fédération fo
cheminots
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
cette nouvelle réunion ce matin entre
les partenaires sociaux le patronat à
matignon tous reçu par le premier
ministre et plusieurs ministres
également est ce que ça peut faire
avancer les choses selon vous non non
elle confirme toujours les mêmes
inquiétudes
l'opposition le positionnement notre
organisation syndicale
c'est le principe même du refus d'une
réforme par points et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne cède pas sur sur cette
posture à maintenir un nouveau système
universel
effectivement par la mobilisation il est
oppressé donc on voit des pseudos
avancée mais qu'ils ne sont pas assez de
fonds pour pour faire reculer
l'opposition sociale mais sur
l'initiative de ce matin c'est à dire
que l'objectif c'était de faire un bilan
un peu de la concertation qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
une initiative que vous saluer il faut
jamais s'interdire la discussion et voir
si un moment les revendications sont
considérés le constat qui est fait
malheureusement une nouvelle fois ce
matin
on parle de déclenchement d'un départ à
la retraite à 60 ans mais mais pour la
partie transitoire on maintient
finalement enfin le gouvernement
maintient son âge déquilibre maintient
son système par coin donc aujourd'hui
pour force ouvrière le compte n'y est
pas effectivement faire un point d'étape
des deux premières réunions sur la
conférence de financement ça avait un
sens
sauf que le à la sortie pas satisfaits
des propos du premier ministre
et donc voilà donc pour nous
l'opposition et notamment par la grève
continuera à perdurer pour faire
entendre à ce gouvernement que sa
réforme est inacceptable et sur la
tonalité des discussions de la matinée
parce qu'il ya une crainte quand même
c'est que l'exécutif le gouvernement en
tout cas fassent usage du 49-3 pour
faire passer en force ce projet de loi
est ce que vous avez eu des échos avec
le sentiment que le gouvernement n'en
arrivera pas jusqu'à là jusque là aussi
on compte bien les points à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui
si le lr m
par sa majorité n'a pas besoin de faire
référence aux 49 3 si aujourd'hui le
gouvernement part dans l'optique de
faire appliquer sont 49 3 c'est à dire
qu'au sein même de sa majorité
il y aurait des dissidences à son projet
de réforme
donc nous je vous dis on continue la
pression on continue à expliquer aux
français pourquoi aujourd'hui cette
réforme est toujours inacceptable et
donc 49 3 ou pas de toute façon nous
c'est retrait de la réforme par points
oui parce qu'il ya des textes qu'on l'a
dit tout à l'heure qui agite aussi au
sein de la république en marche
bien sûr donc c'est une question aussi
qui pourra être posée plus tard on va le
voir alors pour revenir aux journées
d'action a qui sont prévues la semaine
prochaine il ya deux dates différentes
pour quelles raisons selon vous est ce
qui est des divisions au sein des
syndicats ce que ça ce n'est pas un
frein justement la lutte contre cette
réforme
non c'est pas une division
fo cheminots notamment puisque c'est
l'organisation syndicale que je
représente sur votre plateau appellera
au 17 et au vin effectivement la l'inter
confédéral fo cgt fsu solidaires
appelaient au vin sauf qu'il y a eu
entre temps une initiative
enfin même avant avant il a été connu
une initiative à la ratp avec une
intersyndicale basé sur l'unsa et fo
solidaires et sud ratp qui appelle à une
journée noire dans les transports lundi
17 février et nous étant une fédération
fo des cheminots en raccord avec et les
revendications du retrait et aussi le
fait de redonner une impulsion à la
contestation par la grève la fédération
fo cheminots lundi a pris la décision de
rejoindre l'appel du 17 février dans
l'unité ça avait été un peu le succès du
lancement de la grève reconductible 5
décembre
donc on estime justement qui a pas de
division et c'est l'unité syndicale qui
doit être priorisé jusqu'à présent
il ya un apaisement dans la poursuite de
la grève des manifestations aussi la
semaine prochaine vous pensez que ça va
repartir et se durcir à nouveau parce
qu'on entre dans une semaine un peu
voilà charnière puisque à cette
conférence sur le financement qui
concerne le texte et puis aussi le
projet de loi qui arrive à l'hémicycle
enfin qui sera donc examinée le 17
février par l'hémicycle
écoutez nous on est l'outil syndical
donc on met à disposition des salariés
le fait de pouvoir s'exprimer pour
continuer à afficher leur mécontentement
à la réforme
donc nous on propose aux salariés est
d'ailleurs le plus largement possible de
s'associer à l'appel du 17 février pour
continuer à peser
effectivement il ya eu un ralentissement
de la grève puisque vous le savez très
bien
les cheminots comme la ratp s'était
engagé dans une grève reconductible
depuis le 5
ils ont fait plus de six à sept semaines
de grève effectivement la seule carte du
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est de jouer
l'usure par le porte-monnaie des
grévistes donc on a dû re gérer un peu
la grève
et puis de toute façon l'objectif de de
ce combat c'est un combat
interprofessionnelle et c'est d'appeler
encore et toujours à l'amplification du
mouvement avec plus de corporations donc
le 17 c'est pour déjà démontré à ce
gouvernement que les cheminots et les
agents de la ratp sont toujours
déterminés et aussi de faire entendre
aux salariés des autres corporations que
l'énergie par la grève est toujours
présente et et qu'on jouera la partition
du retrait jusqu'à faire plier le
gouvernement
dernière question ça concerne la valeur
du point j'aurai votre lecture puisque
valeur du point et d'ancêtres est
indexée sur les salaires et l'inflation
et on parle désormais du revenu moyen
par tête
mais bien sûr ça montre bien encore le
crédit qu'on peut allouer dans les
garanties avancées par le gouvernement
au début ils voulaient l'indexer sur
l'inflation
il est revenu en arrière puisque c'était
c'était encore plus impopulaire donc il
est arrivé sur l'indexation sur les
salaires et puis aujourd'hui il est sur
des valeurs moyennes
on voit bien que la volonté de ce
gouvernement c'est pas d'élever le
niveau des pensions des français bien au
contraire et et la mécanique qui
souhaitent mettre en place sur les
points ça consistera bien un moment à
baisser la valeur du point pour abaisser
la valeur des pensions et obliger les
français à se payer une retraite
complémentaire des systèmes privés et
donc une nouvelle fois le gouvernement
nous démontre que nous avons raison dans
nos revendications est une nouvelle fois
je pense que l'impopularité de sa
réforme est toujours présente chez les
français
merci un philippe herreweghe que je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général fo cheminots
merci merci à vous